so I've read I mean Sarah Brady seems to
be relentlessly posting all their old
text message exchanges which I just
don't think is on anyway why secondly
when I've read them all Jonah Hill's
probably entitled to just lay down some
boundaries isn't he and if she doesn't
want to go along with it well fine and
she clearly didn't really so they spit
up and that's it and they move on but
you won't move on and now must shame him
why well when I first read the text I
thought maybe Jonah Hill was being
unreasonable because if you're going to
date a surfer and they put up swimsuit
photos you can't be that shocked by it
but that was before I knew that it was a
year and a half later he's just had a
kid with his girlfriend so I would just
say she's she's looking for attention
obviously so he was probably right about
the swimsuit photos in the first place
being irritated by them because it was
probably for attention given she won't
give it up now